less than a week after a deadly crash
the community is coming together to
remember 31-year-old cyclist benjamin
black a ghost ride memorial is being
held tonight to honor him madison
kimbrough joins us live near where the
crash happened near the 215 and north
fifth street and madison people in the
area tell you speeding is a big issue
there
[Music]
sasha resident sharing that this is no
surprise as drivers as you can see right
now go way above the speed limit on
these roads the crash happened in this
newly developed area known as
saddlebrook at thule springs in north
las vegas the street has a speed limit
of 25 miles per hour but unfortunately
that hasn't stopped drivers from racing
up and down and police say speed was a
factor in the crash that took ben
black's life early sunday morning a
woman we spoke to the night of black's
vigil who lives in the neighborhood says
things have gotten out of hand in the
last year and a half
no matter what time of day you come out
in the morning might be like seven or
eight o'clock when my son is literally
having to cross the street to go to his
bus stop there are cars literally flying
through here there's times like ten ten
eleven o'clock at night we can be laying
in a bed and it sounds like literally
people are out here drag racing
neighbors say there has been an ongoing
discussion on the community's facebook
page about how to make sure a tragedy
like this does not happen again many
asking the builder kb home to install
speed bumps or street lights in between
intersections as you can see there are
flowers candles and photos from the
vigil that was held for black earlier
this week and the ghost ride memorial
for him starts at 7 30 tonight it's open
to the public reporting in north las
vegas madison kimbrough live local now